Hello, everyone.
And again, welcome to
lecture 6 of CME 295.
So today is actually
an exciting day
because we're going
to cover a topic that
has been trending
over the past year
or so which is LLM reasoning.
And it's actually a
good segue compared
to what we talked
last time, which
was preference tuning, because a
lot of the methods that we used
in lecture 5 are going
to be the ones that we'll
be using as the foundations
for this lecture.
So before we start,
as usual, we're
going to just cover quickly
what we saw in the last lecture.
So if you remember,
lecture 4 and lecture 5
were all about learning
how we can train a model.
So in lecture 4, we
saw the first part,
which was the
pre-training part, which
is the most compute-intensive
step where we basically
teach the model the structure
of text, the structure of codes.
And we do this very large,
large scale training.
So at the end of this first
step, which is pre-training,
we get a model that knows about
code, that knows about language,
but it only knows how to
autocomplete a sequence.
And so that's why we also
saw the second step, which
was the fine tuning step where
we take our pre-trained model
and we try to make it useful.
So one use case that we saw
was for instance, an assistant.
So we tried to tune
it in a way that it
can respond to questions.
And so here, we have this work
of preparing the SFT data, which
is what we call the SFT data,
which is a high quality,
curated data set that we can
use to teach our model on how
to behave.
So at the end of
this second step,
we have our model that is tuned
for a specific task, which
can be responding to queries.
And then last lecture, we
saw this third step, which
was the preference tuning step.
And here the goal is
to align our model
with human preferences.
So we saw, in
particular, RLHF, which
was a common method to do that.
And we saw that there
was two steps to it.
So there was the
first part, learning
to distinguish good from bad
using human preference data,
and then there was
this second step,
which was this RL stage, which
is going to be useful today.
So in particular,
if you remember,
we had drawn a comparison
between the RL setup
that you may be familiar
with outside of this class,
where we have an agent
that is interacting
with the environment and the
way that it interacts with it,
is that given a
state that it is in,
it can take an action
following a policy, which
is nothing else than
just a probability
distribution over actions.
So given a state, our
agent can take an action
following this policy.
And at the result of this,
it receives some reward.
And we saw last
lecture that we have
this nice comparison between the
traditional RL setup and the LLM
setup.
And so here, our, quote unquote,
agents is just simply the LLM.
The environment that
it interacts with
is just a set of tokens
that it can predict over.
So given an input that
it has received so far,
it can predict what the
next token could be,
which is the action.
And it does that using the
probability distribution that
is the result of, I
guess, the LLM prediction.
And we saw that we can
obtain human preferences
for each completion.
So you have a prompt,
you have a completion,
and you get those
human preferences.
And this is the
one that you then
use in order to tune the LLM.
Because here, this step is
about aligning the model
with human preferences.
And here, the human preferences
is encapsulated in the reward.
And so we saw that the loss
function during the RL stage
is composed of two parts.
So the first part is this
advantage maximization.
And we saw that that advantage
was based on the rewards.
And it has some
baseline to just reduce
the variance of the gradient.
So we have that part.
But we also saw
another part, which
was that we don't want
our model to deviate
too much from either
the previous iteration--
so we don't want the model to
change too much from iteration
to iteration--
but we also don't want our model
to change too much compared
to our initial model,
like our base model.
And here, it's the SFT model.
And the reason why we don't
want to change too much
is because our model has
already learned a lot.
It's already quite
performant in what it does.
And what we want
is to just align it
with human preferences, which is
not something for which we want
the model to change completely.
And I think that
was the part that I
think was a little bit scary,
which was the actual loss
functions.
So if you remember,
the main algorithm
that is typically used
in the RLHF setting
is PPO, which stands for
proximal policy optimization.
And there is this
one variant that's
called PPO CLIP, which is
such that it clips the updates
from one iteration to another.
So here, if you remember, R
is actually not the reward,
it is the ratio.
And it's a confusing notation.
So it's the ratio between
the current policy
and the old policy.
And the old policy
here is the policy
that is at the
previous RL iteration.
So what we do is that we have
a clipping mechanism such that
the ratio cannot go beyond
some certain thresholds,
such that we do not want to
incentivize the model to make
too big of an update.
And we saw another
variant of PPO
which is called PPO-KL penalty.
And this variant uses the KL
divergence to penalize the model
from changing too much.
So if you remember in
the original PPO paper,
we used the old, quote
unquote, old version
of the model, which is the one
that the previous RL iteration.
But in modern day RLHF
training, this KL divergence
is typically applied to the base
model, which is the SFT model.
So I guess long story short
is we have these two PPO
variants that were variants
that were introduced
in the original PPO paper.
But in modern day RLHF
training, we typically
have some combination, some mix
of these two loss functions.
Cool?
So up until now,
we've seen what I
want to call vanilla LLMs, which
are LLMs that take something
as an input, let's
say a prompt, and just
respond with some answer.
And so those vanilla LLMs,
they have a lot of strength
that you can enjoy.
So first of all, we had
seen that those LLMs,
they know a lot about
structure, of the text,
they know a lot about codes.
So in particular, if you
want to debug your code,
I guess they are great to
find where the error is.
They are great to
generate codes.
They're also great to
generate essays or poems.
They're really,
really good at that.
But I do want to call
out some weaknesses.
So the first, I
guess, weakness that I
want to call out in
this vanilla LLMs
is that they have, quote
unquote, limited reasoning.
So typically, if you have
some sophisticated, let's say,
math problem, it will
not really come up with,
I guess, the solution
because maybe it will get
lost in the way
because up until now,
our model has been
really trained to,
I guess, given a prompt,
respond to it using
the next token prediction.
So I guess here, there is
not really a big reason
why it would be able to
solve complicated problems.
So I guess that is one.
So second weakness is
that the LLM that we have
has been pre-trained on a huge
amount of data, which is static,
meaning that the knowledge
that the LLM has acquired
is bound to the cutoff date,
what we call the cutoff
date, at which we cut and
formed our pre-training data.
So I know a few days
ago, we had an election.
So if, let's say, we trained
our LLM based on data
before the election
and let's say today,
we ask it, who is the--
I don't know-- elected
official of let's say X,
it will not be able to answer us
because it does not have access
to knowledge after that date.
So a third weakness is so
far, it's all talk, no action.
So you just prompt your LLM.
But I guess if you
want to let's say,
I don't know, place an order
or don't do some action,
you just kind of do it.
And then I guess the last
weakness, which by the way,
is not an exhaustive list, is
contrary to traditional NLP
models LLMs, they
generate free form texts.
And it's hard to evaluate them
in the framework that we--
I mean, by we is the ML
community has adopted up
until a few years ago.
So if you're familiar
with it, let's suppose
if you worked in the
translation world,
you would use rule-based metrics
like BLEU or for summarization,
ROUGE to evaluate your output.
But then here, LLMs, they can
really do more than just that.
So it's very hard
to evaluate them.
So what I want to
say is that this
is, let's say, a subset
of all the weaknesses
that LLMs can have.
And the last three
are going to be topics
that we'll cover in the next
lecture and in the lecture 8.
And as I mentioned before, the
focus of today is reasoning.
So we'll see how we can improve
the way our LLM reasons.
Cool.
And again, this is a topic
that's been very new.
And by new, I mean
roughly a year.
So almost everything
that we will see
is either from 2024 or 2025.
And I guess we're lucky
because now we have enough
hindsight to just know
which piece is more
important than other things.
And so the goal
for today is going
to be to know what
reasoning models are.
And the second big goal is
to how they are trained.
So hopefully, at the
end of this lecture,
if you have a good answer
to these two questions,
that means that we
have done a good job.
So let's start with
reasoning models.
What are they?
Well, to answer this question,
we first need to, I guess,
define what reasoning is.
And the bad news
here is there's not
a commonly agreed
upon definition
out there of what reasoning is.
So I will try to
define it, I guess,
to the best of my ability.
So here, we define reasoning as
the ability to solve a problem.
And here, by
problem, we typically
think more of math problems
or, let's say, coding problems.
But hopefully, these abilities
can also spread to other fields
as well.
And in order to
solve this problem,
we typically need a
multi-step reasoning process,
a little bit like
when you take an exam,
when you have a question
that's not trivial,
you typically break that
down into several steps
and then go through them, and
then come to the final answer.
So I guess the idea is problems
that are reasoning problems,
they would have some
pattern of that.
So to illustrate
this, let's just
make sure we're all kind
of thinking the same.
So a non-reasoning
question would
be something what is the course
code of Stanford's transformers
and LLM class.
So this one, it's
a knowledge thing.
Everyone knows it's CME 295.
But then as opposed to
that, in contrast to that,
a reasoning-based question
would be maybe a math question.
So for instance,
let's suppose we have
a bear that was born in 2020.
How old is that
bear now in 2025?
So that would be the kind of
question that we're looking at.
Of course, this is super easy.
You can think of something
that's much harder than that,
and this would qualify.
Cool.
So now that we a little
bit what reasoning is, now
we're going to
look at how we can,
I guess, obtain a
model that can deal
with these kinds of prompts.
So the core idea here
is to leverage a concept
we saw earlier in the class.
So I'm not sure if
you remember, but back
in lecture maybe
two or three, we
saw a technique called
chain of thought.
So who remembers what
chain of thought is?
Yeah?
Yes, do you want to
say what that is?
Yeah, exactly.
So the answer is
thinking in steps
instead of just giving
just a blanket answer.
So great answer.
So here, just to illustrate--
yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Great point.
So the question is,
for some questions,
you need to have some
element of context.
So for instance, here,
you need for your LLM
to know that this year, I don't
know, today is November 7, 2025.
So yes great points.
So there are two parts of that.
For that specific
question, so typically
LLMs they have something
that we call preamble.
So something that tells
you about some context.
And typically the
date is something
that we put in the preamble.
So for this very
specific case, the date
would be information that
would already be, I guess,
available to the LLM.
But for some other
problems, you can very well
have information or context
that you do not have.
And in lecture 7, we will
see how we can fetch that.
And it's definitely something
that will be very useful.
But for the sake of today,
we will consider this more
as being an extension of
reasoning models as opposed
to something that is
foundational to how they work.
But we'll respond to this
part, I guess, next lecture.
Cool.
And so here, we are
about to illustrate what
a chain of thought looked like.
And so here, instead of
having, as you mentioned,
just a blanket
answer, what we want
is to explain also
the reasoning.
So the way chain of
thought did that was
by having some in-context
learning examples that
explicitly the reasoning
to encourage the model
to also do that before
providing the answer.
So that's the rough--
it's not the rough idea.
It's the idea behind
chain of thought.
And here, what we want
to do is to do that,
but at a much larger scale.
So I just want to
build an intuition
as to why this may help us.
So LLMs, they are
basically trained
with this next token
prediction objective.
And so the way they respond
to questions that we ask
is typically to sound plausible
in a way to maximize or optimize
for the probability
of the tokens
that you want to
generate to happen.
So if you have a very hard
problem that you're presenting
to the LLM, there
are very few chances
that that problem appeared
in the training sets.
And so here, the idea is to have
the LLM decompose the problem
into tractable ones, and
then rely on the patterns
that it has seen during
training to solve all these
more tractable problems.
And it's a little bit like
you or when we were students.
When we give you a problem, you
try to link it back to something
that you know, that you
have seen at training time,
like during your
studying, to solve them
in order to find the answer.
So I guess that's the intuition.
I guess another reason
that you can think of
is when you let the LLM generate
more tokens, you're just
giving it more
compute, if you think
about it, because at
each generation step,
you have this
whole forward pass.
And when you do that more,
you just give it more compute.
And we will see
there is a term that
is dubbed compute budgets,
which is, I guess,
the budget that
you want your LLM
to have to generate
your response that we
will see later on.
But yeah, so that
also plays a role.
So is everyone clear
on the overall idea
of what a reasoning model is?
Yeah?
Perfect.
So just to make sure, again,
that we're all clear on this,
so up until now we had, quote
unquote, Vanilla LLMs that
had some question as inputs,
and they were responding
with something as output.
And in our case, what we want
is given a question as input,
we don't want to directly
generate an answer.
We first want to think.
And here, I guess we think by
first outputting a reasoning
chain.
And then we provide the answer.
So here, the LLM output
is not just the answer.
It's the reasoning
plus the answer.
And I guess here, I was
saying that this topic
has been very hot and
trendy for the past year.
So this is a little bit of
a preview of the timeline
of reasoning models.
So reasoning itself is a topic
that has been studied for more
than a year, but reasoning
models have started popping out
starting from OpenAI's
release of 01 preview.
And this one was
September of 2024.
And then after
that, you basically
have everyone just
wondering how OpenAI did it.
And so you had all
of these AI labs
trying to see what we
can do to, I guess,
increase the reasoning
abilities of the model.
So you would have
everyone working on this.
And then you had Google's
Gemini 2.0 flash thinking
that was, I think,
released in December.
And then starting in 2025,
there was this DeepSeek R1 paper
that was published in January,
which made a lot of noise
because what they
were able to do
was to match OpenAI's
reasoning ability
performance with a method
that they were actually
describing in their paper.
So that was a big
moment, January 2025.
And then after that, all
of these other models
also had reasoning
abilities added.
So you had some models from xAI,
from Anthropic with Claudes,
and then from other labs
as well, also from Mistral.
So this timeline
is not exhaustive,
but it's just to
show you, I guess,
how recent these models are.
And I guess one
thing to have in mind
is it basically started
at the end of 2024.
Cool.
So I know a lot of
you, if not all of you,
are using LLMs every day as
chat bots like, let's say,
ChatGPT or Gemini.
And so I want you to
know, when the model
that you're interacting
with is a reasoning model--
so I have a question for you.
I was having a discussion
with ChatGPT the other day.
And I was wondering, is this
using a reasoning model.
So what do you think?
If you stare at this screenshot.
Yeah?
Why?
Right, exactly.
So the key word
here is thinking.
Actually, they
put it everywhere.
But when these UIs show
you the thinking process,
so what they do is actually--
so they don't show you actually
the full reasoning process.
And we're going to see why.
But they tell you that
they spend time thinking.
And that time
thinking is actually
the time that is needed to
produce the reasoning chain.
That can be, I guess, more or
less something that takes time.
And so for instance,
for ChatGPT,
you have this thinking that you
can also change from standard
to extended, et cetera.
And you have this for
other models as well.
And in particular,
the, quote unquote,
thought summary that you see
is not the raw reasoning chain.
It's a summary of it.
And the reason
why they do that--
I mean, I'm
hypothesizing-- is one,
because the raw chain
may not be something
that is fully intelligible
from a human standpoint.
Second is because
maybe you as a user,
you don't want to read
the pages and pages.
And then third, this is
going to be what we see.
But if you have the
reasoning chains,
you can maybe train a model
that is trained on these chains
so it can basically mimic
those abilities as well.
So this may be the reasons
why you would typically not
see the raw chain.
And when it comes
to pricing, so we
saw that the output
of reasoning models
are not only the answer, but
also the reasoning itself.
And so you will see in, I
guess, all of these APIs
that you're actually
getting charged for it.
So you're not necessarily
getting all the reasoning chain.
But if you look at the
docs, there's always,
I guess, a sentence
or two, I guess,
that specifies that
you're actually being
charged for output tokens.
And those output tokens, they
also include reasoning tokens.
So I think that's also
a good thing to know.
And I guess from
a user standpoint,
this also gives an incentive
to have the maximum reasoning
ability for a minimum
amount of reasoning token
because you don't
want to pay a lot.
So we're going to see later
on how we can deal with that.
But this is just one
thing that's good to note.
Cool.
So we talked about what
reasoning was, or at least
a tentative definition.
We saw, I guess, the core
idea behind reasoning models.
So now we're going to talk
about some of the benchmarks
that people use to quantify
reasoning abilities.
So the first one, as I
previously mentioned,
is about assessing
the coding abilities.
And so here, the
goal is typically
to solve a coding
problem or to fix a bug.
So you typically have
the following setup.
So given a problem, you want
to produce a solution that
is able to pass test cases.
So if you have a solution
that passes all test cases,
then you have a
solution that works.
And this is our way of
verifying that a response that
was generated is
actually a correct one.
So that's for coding.
So just giving you an overview
of the kinds of benchmarks
that are out there.
So we have HumanEval, which is
the screenshot screenshots here,
which I believe is a set of 100
something coding problems that
were human written, which is
why it's called the HumanEval.
But you have then
CodeForces, which
is coming from a website
of competitive programming
that some of you may know.
And there is also SWE-bench,
which is, I believe,
a set of problems that were
derived from GitHub issues.
So these are real
practical problems.
So you will see that these
reasoning models in the reports,
they typically have results
along these benchmarks.
So this is for coding.
Now for math, the goal
is to solve a problem.
And the way it works
here is given a problem,
you want the answer.
And of course, you're
letting your model,
generate some reasoning.
And so here, what you would do
to verify that your solution
works is by parsing the answer
like so and then comparing it
with some ground truth.
So here, we can really
know if the answer
that your model is producing
is true by comparing the two.
So you will ask me OK,
how do you parse that.
So you can force your
model-- and by force,
I mean in the prompt--
to output the answer in a
way that can be parsable.
Sometimes people, they
just put it in some box
in the box brackets.
So there's a number of
different ways to do that.
And this is how the
problems look like.
So you have some problem.
And then you can let your model
generate some reasoning chain
along with the answer.
And then you have the answer
here that you can compare to.
So I just want to add that
the kinds of benchmarks that
are out there are based
typically on problems that
are actually not that trivial.
So a name that you
will see a lot is aim.
So I'm not sure if
you're familiar with it.
It's a math exam to qualify
for the US math olympiads.
So there is a bunch
of models that I
guess quantify their
performance based on that.
There's also GSM 8-K, which
is a grade school kind of math
problem.
And I guess now
your question maybe,
OK, it's great we have
all these benchmarks,
but what is the
metric that you will
use to quantify that what
you're doing is good or not.
And so there is one metric
that you will see a lot.
And we're going to
see that right now
because it's not that obvious.
So that metric is called pass@k.
So pass@k is, by
definition, a metric
that tries to estimate the
probability that at least one
of k attempts succeeds.
So here, what we're saying
is let's suppose we're, I
don't know, having
some coding problem.
We tell our model to
generate k answers.
And pass@k is the
probability that at least one
of these k answers
passes the tests.
Does that make sense?
So by the way, why
would you have pass@k?
Why would that make sense?
So it's not super trivial.
So you may have
used cases where you
can afford to spend more time
to generate more answers.
If you know that you will get
more chances to get it right,
then you can spend more time
to generate more answers
so that you can
have the right one.
So in a problem like
coding, the good thing
is you can check whether your
answer is correct or not.
And so here, the
idea is if you are
in cases where you can afford
to generate not just one answer,
but multiple
answers, then it may
be worth it to just
spend more time,
spend more compute to generate
more answers if it means
that the probability of
getting it right in one of them
is going to be higher.
There is one technique that
we saw last lecture that
is kind of familiar with this.
Best of n.
Do you remember?
Yeah, roughly.
So best of n is this method
that we saw last week,
which was you
generate n answers.
And you use your reward
model to score everything.
And you take the
best of all of them.
So here, you can think
of it as being the same,
just that we do not
have a reward model,
we have a deterministic,
verifiable way
of checking whether
something is correct.
So it's very similar to that.
And so now we're going to
spend just a few minutes just
aligning our
understanding on how we
can estimate such a quantity.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
So the question is, do you
choose a particular temperature.
So I have a slide on that.
So I'll just hold your
question for a few slides.
Cool.
By the way, if there is any
other questions, happy to--
is there any other
questions on this?
Everyone is super clear?
OK, cool.
So what we want to do here is
to estimate this probability.
But you may tell me,
just generate k attempts
and just count the number
of the attempts that
are correct to estimate that.
But the problem is if
you only do this k times,
your estimate can be very
noisy because by pure chance,
I don't know, you may
have one instance that
has 3 correct out of
5 and the other one 1.
So you want to have an
estimate that doesn't
have that much variance.
So what you do is you typically
generate not k, but n answers.
And out of these
n answers you're
going to have c of them that are
going to be successful, and then
n minus c that are not
going to be successful.
And the question here that you
ask yourself is out of these n
attempts, you want to
quantify the probability
of having at least one out
of k attempts that is right.
So the question here, if you
have those n observations,
if you were to
select, let's say k,
what is the probability
of having at least one
of those k passing?
That's the question.
So we're short on time.
I'm going to actually
derive that right now.
And the reason why
I want to do that
is because the answer is
not necessarily trivial.
And I don't want you to
be too surprised of how
it looks like without
knowing where it comes from.
So we're going to derive that.
So we want to derive
the probability
that at least one attempt
out of k that we select out
of these n samples is correct.
So in order to do that, I'm
just going to write that down.
So pass that k.
So we want the
estimate for that.
So it's going to
be the probability
that at least one attempts
out of k is correct.
So if you've done
some probability,
there is a very
common trick, which
is if you have a
probability of at least one,
it's 1 minus the probability
of having all of them
being incorrect.
Do you all know that trick?
Because we're going
to use that trick.
So it's going to be 1 minus
the probability of having
all k attempts incorrect.
So far so good?
Yeah?
So now we're going to try to
quantify this probability.
So what is the
probability of you
finding an unsuccessful
attempt among these n you
have n minus C unsuccessful.
You have n observations is
going to be n minus C over n.
So it's your first it's your
first unsuccessful attempt.
So now what is the
probability that you
have another unsuccessful
attempts knowing this one?
So you have n minus c minus
1 other unsuccessful attempts
over n minus 1 because
you already took one.
And you continue that k
times n minus c minus k
plus 1 over n minus k plus 1.
Does everyone agree with me?
So here, we are
quantifying the probability
that if we take k
samples randomly
among this n, that all
k1's are incorrect.
So here, we compute this by
computing the probability
that the first
attempt is incorrect.
And then the second
one is incorrect,
knowing that the first one
was incorrect, and so on,
which we have for which
we have this formula.
So if you saw that
in probability class,
it's basically the same as
sampling without replacement.
And now the nice
thing with this is
that you can express that with
a nice mathematical notation
So for people who
know, so n choose
k is equal to factorial n
factorial k factorial n minus k.
So this is by definition of
what this quantity is about.
So we're going to use that here.
So here, we have a
series of products.
So here, we can express
that as factorial
over another factorial.
So here, it's factorial n minus
c over factorial n minus c
minus k.
And then this
quantity, we can also
express that with factorials.
So it's factorial n.
And the numerator is
factorial n minus k.
Everyone agrees
with the math here?
I'll take that as a yes.
And so here, we're
going to somehow pop
the expression above up.
So it's going to be
equal to 1 minus so n
minus c factorial over n
minus c minus k factorial.
And then k factorial.
And then here, we're going to
say it's this one, k factorial k
factorial over n factorial.
So here, I did a trick.
What I did was I
basically multiplied
the numerator and the
denominator by k factorial.
And so here, I have 1 minus--
so this is n minus c over n.
So n minus c choose--
sorry, n minus c choose
k over n choose k.
So this is our
estimates of path at k.
Does everyone agree?
Yeah?
So the reason why
I derived it is
because this formula can be a
little bit daunting to look at.
But it's actually quite
natural because it's only
using some sampling without
replacement considerations.
And so you will see in papers
that people have this pass@k
metric.
So if you were to
compute it, this
would be the formula to use.
Cool.
And special k of
pass@k is pass@1.
And pass@1 is defined
as the probability
of a single attempt succeeding.
So this is something
that you commonly know.
So if suppose you have a
model that produces an answer,
what is the probability
that it's correct?
So if you replace
k with 1, you will
see that this formula
will simplify a lot.
And it will be just a proportion
of successful attempts, which
also makes sense,
just intuitively.
Everyone clear with this?
Yeah?
Great.
So now to your question.
So what do you do
with the temperature.
And you're exactly right.
When you generate these
solutions multiple times,
something that will
influence your results
is how diverse the solutions
that you will generate will be.
And this is something that you
indeed use the temperature for.
Now so what is the relationship
between temperature and pass@k?
Do we want low temperature,
do we want a high temperature,
or do we want
something in between?
Well, if you take a
very low temperature,
you know that your
solutions will be good,
but they will not be diverse.
So if you increase the number
of samples that you generate,
that quantity will
not change, which
is seen with this graph
with the T equal to 0.
It doesn't change.
But then when you
have T equal to 0.2,
now it's increases because
you have some diversity.
But if you increase this
temperature too much,
then you will have the
diversity that you want.
But they will also harm the
performance of your predictions,
because maybe the tokens
that were not that likely
will become likely.
And so here, on the opposite
side, we have t equal 1.2
here, which is extreme in this
example, which is not the best.
So I guess to respond to you,
typical temperature choice
would be something that is
not too large, not too small.
And I believe in this
example is t equal to 0.8
that I think produces the best
results towards the bigger
samples.
But then here, I
guess it's not clear.
Maybe 0.4.
So that's why you will
see that in papers,
people always specify
the temperature
that they chose to produce
the benchmark results.
So that's why it's good
to have that in mind.
So these are the main
metrics that people use
but not the only ones.
There's another one
that you may see,
which is called
consensus at k, which
is the answer that is coming
from the highest number of times
that the answer appears
among your generations.
And you can think of the
self-consistency technique
as being very related to that.
So you may see that.
And then the other metrics that
you will see in those benchmarks
are typically the
ones that you're
familiar with like accuracy,
exact match, and so on.
I took a lot of time
on this first part.
I think I need to
go a bit faster.
But does that roughly
make sense so far?
Yeah?
So right now, I hope you
what a reasoning model is.
So now we're going to go into
the most interesting part
of the lecture, which is how can
we build such a reasoning model.
So we know we want
our reasoning model
to produce a reasoning chain.
But right now, we don't really
how to do that at scale.
And this is going to be the
main focus in this part.
So here the idea is to
somehow incentivize the model
to produce a chain of
thought or reasoning chain
before answering.
So the problem with that is
that reasoning chains writing
is a very tough task,
especially for, I guess,
long reasoning chains.
And for that,
let's suppose if we
were to go look into our
toolbox of the techniques
we have learned so far,
maybe we can think,
OK, we can use SFT to do that.
But the problem with SFT is
you need high quality data,
and in particular,
you would need
to write all of these
reasoning chains.
Let's suppose you do not
have this reasoning chains.
So how do you do that?
You would typically
write them from scratch.
But that is very hard.
So that's one, I guess,
one vote to not do SFT,
if we don't have any
reasoning chains.
So the second reason here
is, or the second fact,
is that the way
the model reasons
may be different from
the way we reason.
And for that, maybe a
human written reasoning
may not be the best way to teach
the model on how to reason.
So that's the second
fact, which is
going against having some
human written reasoning
chains as SFT data.
And then the third
fact that I want to say
is we just saw that
these reasoning tasks,
they have a very natural reward,
which is actually verifiable.
So for coding, you know
if your thing works,
if it passes some test
cases, if it compiles,
and for math, you know if
it works if the answer is
the same as your ground truth.
So naturally, you do
have a reward signal.
So we saw there's
a reward signal.
SFT is not a great way
to start from scratch.
Well, what do you do?
Well, let's try RL then.
And the good thing
is last week, we
saw how RL works in
the case of LLMs.
So I guess that's
a great timing.
So how would we do that?
So just as a reminder, we
want to teach our model
to solve these more
complicated problems.
And we also want to teach
it to reason before.
So in order to do
that, we first want
to have a reward that checks
whether the reasoning chain is
there.
So here, you can
do that by simply
checking whether the model has
produced a reasoning chain.
And you can check that
by checking the presence,
let's say, of the think,
start, and end token
that you can instruct
your model to use
to insert its reasoning chain.
And then the second
reward that you
want to have is to check that
the solution that it produced
actually works.
And so here, as
we mentioned, this
is something that you can
actually do for the benchmarks
that we care about.
So for codes, you would check
that it works for all cases.
For math, you would
just verify with respect
to the answer being the
same as the ground truth.
So we also have that.
So in summary, we
will run RL, and we
will run RL using a reward that
is a combination of checking
whether the thing
tokens are here
and that the end
result is correct.
And we saw that both of
them, we can do this easily.
No need for a model.
So let's suppose you do that.
Let's suppose you do
RL on search rewards.
Well, the nice
thing that you see
is if you plot the performance
of the model with respect
to one of those benchmarks that
I mentioned-- so here it's aim.
So if you remember, it's
the math benchmark--
you see that as you
perform your RL steps,
the performance of the
model on those benchmarks,
they actually increase.
And they actually increase
quite significantly.
So the graph here is actually
coming from the training
of DeepSeek R1--
actually, R1-Zero here, which
we will see a little bit more
in detail with Shervine
how it actually works.
But you can see that if you
incentivize the model to think
and produce the right
answer, it can actually
learn quite meaningfully,
only with these two
verifiable rewards.
But now you may
wonder, let's suppose
I'm teaching my model to think,
well, not all prompts are equal.
There are some
prompts that do not
need the model to think
too much as opposed
to other prompts which would
need a little bit of thinking.
So there has been
a lot of, I guess,
work happening in
the community as how
to control the amount of
thinking that the model does.
So you have things
like dynamic budget
that you will see out
there, how can we make sure
that the model does not
overthink on questions that
do not need too much thinking.
So for this, you
can have something
like a quick classifier, let's
say, that runs on the prompt
and tells you whether
it's something that
is kind of a high thinking kind
of problem or a low thinking
one.
But this is more
of an open problem.
But this can be one solution.
So the second one
is those LLMs, they
have a limited context window.
So when the LLM
thinks, it needs to.
Also be aware of how much
context length is left.
It cannot think too much also
because of that limitation.
So you need to also have
that context awareness.
So there has been some work
to also force the model
to either think more or stop.
So there is this
term, budget forcing,
that I think was introduced
in this paper, S1.
So the idea here is if you want
your model to continue thinking,
you're going to introduce
some tokens mid-way to force
it to think more.
And such tokens are,
for instance, weights.
I think there is
another solution.
So actually, it's a slide that
I have not really talked about.
So if you look at
this reasoning chain,
sometimes the model will
output something like,
oh wait, wait, wait, I think
I found something else.
And typically, the
model would go again
on another kind
of reasoning path.
And this can be one way
to incentivize your model
to think more.
Or another term can be,
OK, your time is up.
Now my answer is, and it will
force your model to respond.
And then if you think
about it, your model
gives tokens in its
reasoning chain,
but models may think on
some other space, maybe
not in the language space.
So there is also a line
of work around having
some continuous thoughts.
Basically having this thinking
token actually not be tokens,
but be hidden
representations that
can be more meaningful,
but also more compressed.
So you have a bunch
of papers on this.
So there's one that we linked,
which is actually from 2024.
But I think even a
few days ago, I also
saw another paper on that.
So it's very much
active area of research.
And I guess just
like that, I guess
we saw that the way that we want
to scale our model is with RL.
I guess is everyone
convinced of that?
Did I convince you well
with those arguments,
or does anyone have
any questions on this?
And I guess here,
I want you to have
a takeaway, which is we want to
use RL to incentivize our model
to think more if we
start from scratch,
meaning we don't have
reasoning chains.
So is everyone good with this?
Yeah?
Kind of, yeah.
So I'll take this as a yes.
So now we're going to
see the algorithm that we
use to perform that RL step.
And you may have heard
this acronym a lot.
So this algorithm that we
will see is called GRPO.
And GRPO has been
released in 2024.
And it has been the go
to RL algorithm for all
these reasoning tasks, or for
this reasoning training tasks.
So what is GRPO?
So GRPO stands for group
relative policy optimization.
And it is an RL algorithm
which, very much like PPO,
aims to do these two
things we talked about.
So the first one is to
maximize advantages.
And if you remember, advantage
is something that tells you
whether what you're producing
as an answer is better
than what you would expect.
So this is the first part.
And then the second
part is that you do not
want to deviate too much from
either the old model, which
is the model at the
previous iteration,
or the base model, which
is the model at SFT stage.
So GRPO is also doing the same
thing as PPO in that sense.
But then there is
a key difference.
And that difference lies in
how it computes the advantage.
So if you remember, PPO
estimated the advantage
by taking the rewards, which
is at the completion level.
So you know you
have your prompts,
and you have a response,
a full response.
And then based on those two
elements, you have a reward.
So what PPO did was take
that into consideration
along with something else
that it was training jointly
at training time, which was
called the value function.
And the value
function objective was
to try to predict
what that reward was
if we were to continue
generating the tokens following
the policy.
And if you remember, the
advantage here is actually,
in the case of
PPO, was something
that we obtained based
on a very complex formula
that we did not see, actually.
But that's called a generalized
advantage estimation.
That is a method to
estimate those advantage.
And the big limitation
with that was
that you had to train a
value function jointly
with your policy.
So this big bottleneck.
And in contrast to that,
GRPO says, well, we're
not going to do that.
We're going to
take a completion.
compute each reward.
And we're going to compare it
with the average of rewards
of completions for
that same prompt.
So I'll give you an example.
So let's suppose we
have a math problem.
So what we're
saying here is we're
going to generate
multiple completions
for that same prompt.
And for each prompt
and completion--
and the prompt is shared.
So for each completion, we're
going to measure, I guess,
a relative measure of the
reward for that completion
and all the other rewards
of the other completions.
So this will give us
an idea of how much
better or how much worse
is it from, I guess,
the rest of the group.
And so this is going
to be our advantage.
So the big benefit here is that
we do not use value functions.
We do not use that.
The only thing we do is
we sample not just one,
but multiple
completions in order
to compute the average of
the rewards of the group.
Does this make sense?
Oh, yeah.
So what would you do instead?
So the question is,
why would you do that.
Well, the traditional RL
algorithms, just for reference,
they have been developed before
all these LLMs became a thing.
So for instance,
PPO was a method
that I believe is from 2017.
So these quantities,
they may make
a lot of sense in some
setups, but maybe not
in the language world.
And I guess here,
the idea is let's try
to think of something that tells
you how good your completion is
just in the relative sense.
But here, I guess
what the authors
want to do is to not
have to have this very
expensive joint model
that they have to train
and think of another
relative way of doing that.
So I think that's the
high level intuition.
And I guess here, the idea is
let's just sample multiple times
and see how one response
is comparing to the others,
and then use that as
some kind of baseline
to put this reward into context.
So for instance, you
may have a math problem
that's kind of easy.
And if you have a high
reward for that one,
maybe it's because the problem
was easy to start with.
But if you have, let's
say, very hard problem,
if you have the
correct answer, then
you want to make sure you're
incentivizing your model
to upweight those tokens
much more because if you
find a good solution, it's a
good solution to a hard problem.
So you want to somehow bake
that in into your advantage.
So that's the intuition.
So GRPO was
developed a year ago.
And a year ago, LLMs
were everywhere.
So this is also taking into
consideration, I guess,
what LLMs are incentivized
to do in some sense.
So yeah, I would
think it that way.
Does that help?
Cool, cool.
Any other question on this?
Well, don't worry if
you have questions
because we will have a
walkthrough of exactly how it
works.
So here, we're going to go
through the exact same thing,
but illustrate it.
So in the GRPO case,
we're taking a query,
and we're passing that
through our policy
model, which is our LLM
that we're trying to train.
And here, what we
said was we want
to generate not one, but
multiple completions.
Let's suppose g completions.
And each of these
query completions--
So you have g such pairs.
You pass them through the reward
model that gives you g rewards.
And what you want is to
compute the advantage which
puts all these rewards
into their context.
So we saw it was basically
the reward minus the average.
But it's actually
not exactly that.
So it's reward minus the average
over the standard deviation
of those rewards is
how they defined it.
By the way, we will
see that it may not
be the best way to do it, but
we'll see that in a second.
And we use those advantages
to then tune our policy model.
And while we do
that, we, of course,
don't want to deviate too much
for from the reference model.
So we have this KL divergence
term as well over here.
So that is GRPO.
And we're going to see
right now exactly how this
worked with PPO.
So with PPO, if you remember,
you have your prompt.
You have your query.
You pass that through
your policy model.
And you only have
one completion.
And you pass your prompt
and your completion.
So this pair, you pass it
through the reward model,
and this gives you a reward
for that whole completion.
Now, there's one
thing we did not
see last time, which is more
of a implementation detail.
But we also have a KL
divergence term that is,
comparing the
probability of each token
with the probability
of the token
for from the reference model.
And from an
implementation standpoint,
we also typically incorporate
that in the rewards.
So we have something
like a per token rewards
where only the last
token has the reward
of the whole completion.
But then everyone has
also a KL divergence term.
So that one is not super
important here to have in mind.
But it's just good to know that
people implement it that way.
So once you have those
rewards, you also
have a value function that
this one is per token.
This one tries to
quantify the rewards
if you were to
continue generating
the rest of the sequence
following the policy.
And we saw there is this method
that we're not going to see.
That is called generalized
advantage estimation
that takes in those
two quantities
and computes the advantage.
You can think of it as
some complicated formula.
And you have your advantage
that you use to tune the policy.
And that's it, which is
a complicated compared
to this one.
So GRPO, you use advantages
that are a result of this group
computation.
But then PPO, you
have an advantage
that is a result of rewards
and the value function,
which is per token.
Yeah?
So what are the
models at stake here?
So here, we have
some models that we
use that are, quote
unquote, frozen,
that are not the
ones that we train.
So for GRPO, we have
the reference model
that we do the KL divergence on.
And then we have
the reward model,
which we trained in the past.
And the same is
the case for PPO.
Now, one thing to note is
that in the reasoning case,
we are actually not
training a reward
model because we know how to
tell whether a solution is
correct or not.
We actually have a
verifiable reward.
So in the reasoning
case, we're actually
not having any
reward model at all.
It's the same for both.
Now what is different is
the models that we train.
So in the GRPO case, we
only train the policy model,
whereas in the PPO case,
we train the policy model
and the value function
the value model.
And this is the key difference.
So until now, we've seen only
drawings and illustrations.
So let's see some math.
So you have the GRPO
loss function at the top
and the PPO loss
function at the bottom.
They look scary.
But we're going to see
together some similarities
and some differences.
So what is one similarity?
Both of them, they
operate on the ratio
of the probability
of the current policy
and the probability
of the old policy.
So as the first point in common.
The second point in common
is that both of them, they
try to keep the updates within
some region, not too wide.
And they do that with
the clipping mechanism
that we saw last lecture.
So I recommend that you
just go through these charts
that we saw together.
When the advantage is positive,
how the loss looks like.
And when the
advantage is negative.
So this clipping
function just allows
you to not make updates that
are too big, that are too wide.
But now.
What is different.
So in the JPO case,
the KL divergence
is actually something
that is explicitly
part of the objective function.
Whereas for the PPO
case, this KL divergence
is typically part
of the advantage.
So this is more of
a technical detail.
But a few minutes
ago I had mentioned
that from an
implementation standpoint,
we typically incorporate
the KL divergence
within the rewards that are
considered in the advantage
computation.
So that's one difference.
And then the second
difference is
the way we compute advantages.
So we saw that GRPO,
we typically compute
rewards for each
completions, and then we
compare them with the other
completions from the group.
Whereas for PPO, we use the
rewards and the value models.
So far so good?
I think I have some other
things I want to talk about.
But before that, I just
want to open the floor
if anyone has any questions.
This is very
technical, by the way.
Very technical, probably the
hardest part of the whole class.
So it's completely
normal to, I guess,
take some time to digest that.
And if no one has any questions,
I actually see this as more
of an alarm for myself
because this is maybe--
I don't know.
So let me if there's
any questions on this.
And yeah, absolutely no problem
to have any kind of questions.
Is everything super clear?
Super clear?
So just tell yourself
that these algorithms,
they're just there to tune
your model in the RL stage.
PPO is heavily used in the
preference tuning framework,
where you try to tune
your model to align it
with human preferences,
and is commonly
used for these reasoning
based training.
So I think if you tell
yourself that is something.
And then the second
thing you need
to tell yourself is GRPO differs
from PPO in that GRPO does not
need a value function.
It actually computes
its advantages
by comparing the rewards with
respect to other completions.
And then the PPO, it
takes in the reward,
it takes in the value,
and then compares
the two to get the advantage.
So if this is making sense,
I think this is already
a very good thing.
So is this making sense?
Yeah?
I would also recommend to
just rewatch the recording.
So we're recording this.
This is very heavy
and can be technical.
So just rewatching it a
few times I think can help.
So we have 11 minutes before
giving it to Shervine.
And what we're going to
see now is some extensions
of the GRPO work that was done
last year that people have
done in the past few months.
So this research is
going back to early 2025,
but it has gained
enough traction for us
to talk about it in this class.
So if you remember
what I mentioned
in the beginning of the
lecture, reasoning tokens
are being charged
to you as a user.
So you don't want to pay a lot.
You don't want to pay too much.
So you want your model
to do what you want,
but you do not want it to
generate too much so that you're
getting charged for it.
And also from the
provider side, I
guess it's much better
to be more efficient.
So there is an
incentive to see what
we can optimize from the
output length perspective.
So if you see the
training of these models,
one thing that you notice
is that as you train it
in the RL stage, the
output increases in length.
So here this graph shows as
a function of the RL step
the average length per response.
So you see, from an
empirical perspective,
that the answer that
the LLM is outputting
is getting longer and longer.
And this is mainly
coming from the reasoning
chain that is being more
and more sophisticated.
And when you compare
this graph with respect
to how the performance
of the model improves,
you see that this
increase here in length
is actually correlated with
an increase in performance.
And you might say,
OK, it's good.
But then there comes a
stage over here where
the performance-- so
it's on the left--
the performance of your
model tends to stabilize,
but then your output length
still continues increasing.
And so a lot of people
have looked at these charts
and they're like, OK,
there's something going on.
So here, what we're going to do
is to look at this phenomenon
and see how people have
tried to mitigate it.
So little Warning-- this is
also a little bit technical.
So please bear with me.
There is one formula that I
will try to explain to the best
that I can.
But there is some
amount of math.
So in order to understand
what's happening,
we need to look
at the GRPO loss.
And the loss is the one
that I just mentioned here.
Seems like a very
complicated formula,
but it's not really
a complicated one.
I'm going to just explain in
plain terms what this means.
So J of GRPO--
J means objective function.
So the objective
function of GRPO
is to maximize this
quantity, which
is a function of how
much your model changes
with respect to the old one.
So it's these ratios that
you see in the slide.
And you have this
clipping mechanism
that prevents your updates
from being too wide.
And then you have
the KL divergence
on the right, which prevents
your model from being too far
from the base model.
The reference model.
And then you have
these summations here
and the summations here.
They correspond to you
going through that process
for all completions
in your group.
Because remember if you
have a prompt you sample
several times have
several completions,
and then you do that for
every token of your output.
So here, the first summation is
over the indices of your group.
The second summation
is over the indices
that are with respect to the
token number in your sequence.
And so here, I guess let's
just think for a second,
if we were to swap--
I'm not sure if you
see what I did here.
I just swapped the 1 over
length of output number I.
Just swapped it here.
I'm going to explain
why I did that.
So if you look at
this, this is a factor
that is only a function
of which output you're in.
So if you're in a
very long output,
this will be 1 over
a very long output.
It will be a small number.
If it's a short
output, it's going
to be 1 over a short number.
It's going to be a big number.
And the term on the right
of this is token specific.
So in other words,
the contribution
of a token with respect
to the objective function
depends on the
output that it is in.
So if the token is
in a short sentence,
it's going to have a
higher weight bigger weight
than in a longer sentence.
Until now, is everyone
agreeing with me?
Yeah?
So with that being
said, I'm just
going to rephrase
what I just said,
if you are in a short
sentence, your weight
will be bigger than if you're
in the bigger sentence.
Now let's try to think about
this in terms of the advantage.
If you are in the case of a
token being in an output that
is of advantage,
that is positive,
that means that we
would want to upweight
the probability of this
token happening again,
much more for short sentences
as opposed to longer ones.
And at the same time, you want,
when the advantage is negative--
so it's not you want.
It's just that
this formulation--
makes tokens that
are in short outputs
be down weighted even
more compared to when
they're in a long output.
And so this is the problem.
This is a bad
incentive because what
you're telling your model is if
you have a short bad sentence,
it is worse than if you
have a long bad sentence.
So that's the idea here.
So I'm just going to just
rephrase what we said until now.
The fact of dividing by
the length of the output
is incentivizing your model to
downweight even more tokens.
If the tokens in
a short output, it
will be down weighted even more
than if it's in a long output.
So in other words,
what you're going to do
is to prefer longer
bad outputs as opposed
to shorter bad outputs.
And this is what people
are hypothesizing
that is making the output
length bigger and bigger.
And we're going to
see that in a second.
So what people did was
do something about this.
So this 1 over
length of o, people
wanted to do something about it.
So there is one paper that
came out in March, DAPO--
quite a popular paper now--
that actually equalizes this
token level contributions.
And so here, this
normalization factor
is now common to all tokens.
And there is another
paper that's called--
So I think it's GRPO done right.
But it's Dr. GRPO So I'm not
sure how you pronounce it.
But that paper actually proposes
to remove the factor altogether.
And when you do
that, if you compare
the GRPO versus the one that
equalizes the token level
contributions, you see
that if you plot reward
as a function of output
length, your model
will stop increasing its
length again and again.
So if you actually look deeper,
samples that are correct
are actually having
a length that
is matching with the GRPO one.
But for incorrect solutions,
here, the corrected policy
is having an average length
that's much lower than the ones
from GRPO.
So that's the
bottom right charts.
And that is actually
making-- so this adjustment
is actually making the
intended consequence.
So that's one very important--
I think very important--
one important modification
that people typically apply.
And I'm looking at the time.
In one minute, I
will just tell you
about some other
modifications that people do.
So there is a
modification with respect
to the standard deviation
that is within the advantage
formula that's biases
towards in terms
of the difficulty
of the problem.
Because if let's suppose you
have a very hard problem,
most of your completions
will be, let's say, failures.
And so your standard deviation
will not be super large.
So this can cause problems.
And then there is
another modification
that people typically
also consider,
which is having
different epsilons.
And if you remember
that epsilon influences
how much you're able to
change the policy from one
iteration to another.
And the idea here is that if
the probability of your token
is very low, it is kind
of unfair to just give it
a small epsilon to grow because
this epsilon is multiplied.
So I'm just going
to write that down.
And then it's going
to be Shervine--
where is this?
So we actually want
the ratio of pi over pi
all to be roughly in between
those bounds roughly.
So in other words, it's 1
plus epsilon times pi of old.
So if this one is very low, you
cannot really change your value
too much.
And you don't want to
have an epsilon that's
too high because you don't want
big probabilities to suddenly go
to 0.
So you want to introduce an
asymmetry between the lower
and the upper bounds.
So this was a lot.
Any questions on this?
We're running short on time.
We're going to have some time
after the lecture in case
you have any questions.
And with that, I'm going
to give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine, for
covering all the hard parts.
Now it's going to be a
bit easier because we're
going to see how all
of this comes together.
And in particular, we're going
to focus at the DeepSeek papers
and exactly how they used all
these techniques that Afshine
covered into building
these reasoning models.
So what we saw at
previous lectures,
what, quote unquote,
traditional LLMs.
So you started from a
pre-trained base model
where you did a next token
prediction on a bunch of texts
of the internet.
And then out of
this, you proceeded
to do your alignments, which
was composed of SFT and then RL.
So not the reasoning style
RL, but the regular one.
And then the SFT was
instruction tuning.
And we're going to see how these
newer models are being trained.
And I think the example
of the DeepSeek R1 paper
is a great one because they
go into multiple stages.
First, into showing
how powerful can the RL
stage be if you apply the
verifiable rewards that Afshine
mentioned.
And then based on the
observations of the performance
that you get out of
it, how to devise
a full pipeline of getting a
super powerful model that they
call R1.
So, respectively, a
proof of concept and then
a full reasoning model.
Does that sound good?
OK, great.
So now let's start
with the recipe
that DeepSeek folks use
for the R1-Zero model.
So they first started
with a pre-trained model,
trained on next token
prediction on the latest
architectures with all
the bells and whistles.
So you recall from
previous lectures,
we talked about a
mixture of experts.
So they have this,
and they reuse
a trick called multi-latent
attention, MLA,
that they had introduced
in DeepSeek V2.
And we had talked
about it as well.
You can see, in
their architecture,
they use a pre norm in
their transformer blocks.
So they have a
typical Bayes LLM.
So they perform next
token prediction on it.
And then this is
where the fun starts.
So instead of going ahead with
an alignment strategy that
consists of SFT, they just start
with this pre-trained model
just trained on next
token prediction.
And it hasn't seen any
supervision so far.
And they apply the
technique that Afshine just
mentioned on reasoning data.
So they look at rewards.
And all they incentivize
the model to do
is to increase the rewards
based on the outputs,
like input answer that the model
gives, as well as formatting.
So if you have your think
tokens that Afshine mentioned,
then the reward on the
formatting side would be given.
And the paper gives exactly
the templates over which
they trained the model.
So it's a very simple one.
You have the first
sentences that
set up the stage that say, hey,
you're discussing with the user,
you're an assistant.
And then the reward that I
mentioned regarding formatting
is explained in plain text.
So it says, whatever
you want to think about,
just do it, but put
it into think boxes.
And then once you're
ready to give your answer,
you should wrap it
under like an answer--
basically your answer blocks.
And what you see here
in red is what you
replace by the sample prompts.
And then at the end,
you give the opportunity
to the model to respond.
Does that make sense?
OK, great.
And I'm going to
show you, again,
a graph that Afshine had shown.
So it was done on R1-Zero
where they said that
without any prior
supervision, just having
these as a reward increases
scores on reasoning based
benchmarks.
So this one I think is on AIM.
This like math one.
And you see that the
accuracy improves over time.
And you might think, all is
solved, it's great, no SFT,
and we already have the
best performance possible.
Well, not so easy,
because the authors,
when they looked at
the reasoning chains,
they saw some issues
with it of two kinds.
So first, when the model
was thinking about--
was emitting distinct
tokens, sometimes it
would mix languages.
And you had also syntax issues.
And you could
hypothesize that this
might be the case because
you haven't really
seen any strong supervision
just before that.
And you give the
opportunity to the model
to optimize anything it wants,
but it doesn't really have,
as a background, a strong
supervision signal to anchor on.
So this is one key
challenge that we're
going to see together, how
they try to resolve it.
Does the R1-Zero
process make sense?
Awesome.
So now that we have
seen what R1-Zero
tried to prove, the
fact that with RL only,
you can get reasoning
level performance,
now we're going to see how to
adjust the challenges that we
have seen into a full pipeline.
So that one, they call it R1.
And they start from
the same basis.
So they start from
a V3 base, which
is the pre-trained model
that's DeepSeek had
trained during their V3 paper.
So it was the non-reasoning
version of this model.
So they start from it.
And then instead of
starting directly
to doing the RL stage
that we have discussed,
they try to align
it in a way that
will nicely try to alleviate
the issues we have seen.
So it starts from what they
called as cold start data.
They generated CoTs.
during the R1-Zero stage.
And these CoTs
sometimes had issues.
So they used humans to
rewrite some of these
so that all these CoTs
are compliant when
it comes to formatting
language consistency.
And then they used
these pairs, prompts
and then rewritten prompts,
as data to train SFT on it.
And I think there was no number
given on the number of samples
given to that stage.
But from the wording
of the paper,
it could have been
several orders
of magnitude less than
some of the other stages
that we have seen.
So potentially in the
[INAUDIBLE] case of input output
pairs.
So now that we have
this stage ready,
they continued with the RL
stage that R1 0 would do.
And then we're going to
explore the reward function
that they used.
So not only we have
these verifiable reward
based on the response of
the reasoning model output
that we wanted to have, but also
we have the formatting reward.
And there is something new
that they introduced as well
to counter the effects of
having poor readability
in their thoughts.
There was something called a
language consistency reward
where they use a
very simple heuristic
to assess whether the model
indeed doesn't mix languages.
So I believe it was the ratio
of the tokens in the target
language in the outputted chain.
So they just put that in
order to maximize the amount
of correct language tokens.
Great.
And after this first
pass of RL, they
continued on with SFT with
a very interesting strategy.
So they do it as a larger
scale than the cold start one.
And now they mix both reasoning
and non-reasoning data
in order to make the model
useful to the span of cases
that you as a user might
solicitate the model for.
And regarding
non-reasoning data,
they recycled some
of the data that
was used for their non-reasoning
version of the model for V3.
So about 200k pairs.
And it covers the
domains that we
have mentioned during the
instruction tuning lecture.
So like a broad array of topics.
And then what they
did is that they
added to it a lot of pairs that
are directed towards reasoning.
So the ratio was 3 to 1.
And then the reasoning ones were
generating with a method called
rejection sampling.
So what they did
is that they took
some prompts covering these
reasoning-based fields,
and they used the model
that had been trained
so far to generate a response.
And then based on the
output and with some judge,
they would keep some answers
and reject others such
that the resulting data sets
would be of very high quality.
So this is what they call
by rejection sampling.
It's just the fact of
filtering out any answers that
are not perfect.
And the reason why I guess
they did it automatically
with some LLM judges and so on
is given the scale of the data--
and these were heuristics that
worked pretty nice on that--
you had a question?
No?
So once they were
done with that,
they went on to
a last stage that
was one that might
make you think
about the ones that occur in
non-reasoning model training
pipelines.
So they mix this time
not only reasoning data,
but also non-reasoning ones.
So for the reasoning data, same
kind of reward as we have seen.
But on the
non-reasoning one, you
try to align the model
on characteristics
that make an LLM a helpful
assistant and a harmless one.
So you have this helpfulness
and harmlessness components
of that part of the reward.
And the harmlessness
was a reward
that was applied on the whole
tokens that were outputted.
So not just the
output because you
want the chain of thoughts in
the think section of the answer
to be harmless indeed.
And then the helpfulness
one was more focused
on what you saw
at the user level.
OK, great.
And just to give some
idea of the results
they got, so first,
you notice that
on reasoning-based
benchmarks you
have two clusters of
results that appear.
You have all these non
reasoning based models
that have some performance.
And then the
reasoning-based ones
have unsurprisingly a
performance that is much higher.
And then the second thing that
we observe out of these results
is that R1 was pretty
competitive with respect
to closed source models that
claim to be reasoning-based.
And it was a pretty
interesting moments,
as Afshine had
mentioned, to reproduce
such a level of performance.
OK, great.
So I want to finish this
lecture on an interesting note
of let's say you don't have
a 600B MOE at your disposal.
Let's say you have
a smaller model,
but you want to have
the capabilities
of these large reasoning model.
How would you go about it?
So I just want to give
you a reminder of how
we had dealt with this topic
a few lectures ago when
we talked about distillation.
So at that time, we were just
talking about pre-training
and an instruction tuning where
the data we were dealing with
was fixed.
So for example, for
next token prediction,
you know the text you
want the model to fit on.
For SFT, you have fixed pairs.
You know exactly what
you want to learn.
And what you did was look for
each next token prediction
at the output probability
distribution of a teacher model.
And on your student
model, instead
of fitting a hard label
of the next token,
you fit it instead the whole
probability distribution
of the teacher model
in order to distill
the knowledge of that teacher
model into the student model.
You all remember that?
Yeah?
So now how could you go
ahead with this in this case?
So here, as you have
seen, we don't necessarily
have SFT pairs based on
reasoning out of the box.
So if you want to distill the
knowledge of a teacher model
here, the authors have gone
through an interesting route
that is still
called distillation,
but it's another flavor of it.
So we use the teacher
model here, R1,
to generate some sample
responses including
thinking tokens.
So this is something
that is done offline.
And then in a second
stage, you run this SFT
and fit a smaller
model on your distilled
model, which is typically much
less weights than the teacher
one.
So instead of fitting a
probability distribution
over the next token, you
just fit the entire sequence.
You just try to predict
the same sequence of tokens
that the teacher has outputted.
Does this framing of
distillation here make sense?
Yeah?
Awesome.
And I'm going to conclude here
by looking at the results.
So you can see that the
results, once again,
are very competitive with
closed source alternatives that
claim to be a smaller
version of a reasoning model.
So for example,
o1-mini, you can see
that the numbers here are
competitive with respect
to that.
And then you could also
wonder, but why did you
go through the trouble of just
distilling when you could just
do the same RL techniques.
Well, actually, the authors
have seen that at a smaller size
level, distilling
the knowledge is
more efficient in
terms of performance
than directly
learning from scratch.
All good?
And with that, have
a great weekend.